Ciao ragazzi benvenuti su Anita Stories
Oggi abbiamo una notizia bellissima da
darvi una cosa bellissima però prima
Stiamo andando al negozio di animali
perché dobbiamo prendere un po' di cibo
per la nuova arrivata spoiler Quindi è
una femminuccia e dobbiamo prendere
anche dei giochini Quindi ora andiamo a
sceglierli assieme e voi nel frattempo
Provate a indovinare di che animale si
tratta potrebbe essere un cane potrebbe
essere un gatto potrebbe essere un
riccio potrebbe essere un topo un
elefante non manca più nessuno solo non
si vedono i due leocorni scrivete nei
commenti che cos'è Secondo voi e Ora via
al negozio di animali Guardate questo
Che cos'è un mostro
la mela morsicata qua Forse è
stranissimo è un orsacchiotto è un po'
strano
il polipetto che carino facciamo vedere
che cosa hai preso lì o no si capisce
niente
suonate Il piacere è tantissimo Quasi
sicuramente sì c'è il rischio che se le
mangi perché sono troppo morbida
Guardate che faccia strana che ho
carino È un ariete davvero
una banana
oggi anche la melanzana No no no è
troppo bella Che bella cosa preferisci
banana o melanzana Ok prendiamo la
melanzana
per questo secondo me le fa paura
le patatine
un pinguino Ma questo per essere umani
non è per animali bellissimo cioè così
grande che cosa fa tipo un cane se lo
vorrebbe sbranare questo guarda questo
mi piacerebbe a Berlino per lui perfetto
quasi subito il polipetto c'è un
polipetto qui
Oh Che figo invece il lama hai visto qui
Lama
unicorno è bellissimo Ok ragazzi siamo
tornati a casa Ecco qua i giochini Ora
vediamo quale giochino gli piacerà di
più Anzi Provate a indovinare nei
commenti Secondo voi mi piacerà di più
questo giochino questo topino beige
oppure questo coso che non si capisce
che cos'è
oppure la melanzana perché L'ho scelta
io Vediamo quale le piacerà di più E voi
Mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace qua
sotto e guardate il video fino alla fine
perché alla fine del video scoprirete il
suo nome pronti a conoscerla 3 2 1
E ora vi raccontiamo tutta la sua storia
cioè come l'abbiamo conosciuta Aspettate
che
Ehi aspetta aspetta qua sopra no ok e
impaziente di conoscere i giochi quindi
diamole subito i giochini Ciao Ciao
piccolina
Sì
guarda guarda un po' piccola
Eccola qua è una gattina stupenda e
adesso vi raccontiamo tutta la sua
storia è un po' particolare il modo in
cui l'abbiamo conosciuta ora vi
raccontiamo tutto ma prima diamo dei
giochini Così nel frattempo si diverte a
Vitale dice che è un riccio ma Ah le
corna tipo
le orecchie non sono le corna sembra che
le piaccia Ciao amore Ti piace questo
gioco
Che carino ha solo due mesi più o meno
ha detto la veterinaria
Guarda un po'
e questo sembra molto interessata questa
ancora annusando è un po' diffidente
ancora dice ma che cos'è questa cosa il
gioco o no mi è piaciuta
credo che l'abbia un po' snobbato Questo
gioco non le piace tantissimo forse
perché non fa rumore come quell'altro È
vero credo che le piace di più la pulce
la melanzanina che carina devi vedere
Merlino dietro come sta controllando
tutto il Merlino è il davvero maggiore e
la cosa più bella che Merlino l'ha
accettata subito appena l'ha conosciuta
perché lei si intrufolata subito in casa
Merlino subito l'ho accettata ed è super
carino e le fa da fratello maggiore
L'unico problema è che circa è un po'
arrabbiata Infatti Circe non è molto
contenta della sua nuova sorellina Ma
abbiamo visto che ci vuole un po' di
tempo per un gatto accettare un altro
gatto piccolino Quindi pazientemente
speriamo che prima o poi faranno
amicizia tanto A Circe piace tantissimo
stare fuori in giardino e giocare fuori
invece a lei piace un sacco stare in
casa e giocare in casa quindi speriamo
che prima o poi ci si abituerà la sua
nuova sorellina Ma ora melanzana Time
che in inglese si dice eggplant si può
dire in due modi explat O overfin Allora
vediamo un po' se gli piace questo
giochino dai Questo l'ho scelto io Dai
il gioco
sembra che si sia divertendo da
piccolina nel frattempo che gioca io vi
racconto la sua storia perché la sua
storia è incredibile guarda i giochi
della nuova piccola ti piacciono magari
piacciono anche a Merlino
non li puoi distruggere però eh Questi
sono giochi piccolini per gattino se li
Mordi tu dici si distruggono subito
qualche giorno fa una mattina Vitale ha
sentito dei miagolii pensava fosse Circe
Però è strano Perché Circe non miagola
quasi mai
A questo punto si è affacciato alla
finestra e c'era lei fuori nel nostro
giardino che miagolava e miagolava in
continuazione
in continuazione allora siamo usciti
fuori e lei appena ci ha visto c'è
subito venuta incontro volevo subito
entrare dentro casa e infatti è entrata
subito dentro casa e si è messo nel
divano come se fosse a casa sua
praticamente noi Poi abbiamo provato a
chiedere ai vicini di casa Se fosse
magari il gatto di qualche vicino che è
scappato ma non è il gatto di nessuno
quindi molto probabilmente è stata
abbandonata poverina Anche perché
piccolina e quando è arrivata aveva un
problema agli occhi aveva un po' di
congiuntivite E respirava un po' male
quindi il giorno dopo L'abbiamo portata
subito dal veterinario e l'abbiamo
curata la stiamo ancora tuttora curando
però si è già ripresa tantissimo quindi
praticamente non siamo stati noi a
scegliere lei ma è stata lei a scegliere
noi come famiglia e noi siamo
felicissimi di averla adottate di avere
un nuovo membro della famiglia attoris
all'inizio Vitale quando mi ha chiamato
ha detto niente faccio vedere vieni a
vedere in giardino vieni C'è qualcosa io
ho pensato Che strano cosa ci sarà in
giardino che Vitale mi sta chiamando
Così in questo modo così spaventato
quindi sono corsa in giardino e ho visto
lei ho visto lei che miagolava e mi
guardava miao miao piccolissima e
All'inizio pensavo fosse uno scherzo
quindi ho detto Vitale Ma stai
scherzando Cioè pensavo che avesse preso
lui la gattina e mi avesse fatto tipo
una sorpresa ma in realtà No È lì che è
arrivata da noi non sei stata dove sia
arrivato Probabilmente è stato
abbandonato ma adesso facciamo la prova
dei tre giochi perché dobbiamo capire
qual è il tuo preferito qualsiasi
cartoncini e preferisce il graffiatoio a
quanto pare
la melanzana Ma insomma ti abbiamo
appena comprato questi giochini e non te
ne frega niente
Ciao piccola Ti piace di più tra questi
dobbiamo sapere chi ha indovinato
vediamo da quale va da quello in cui
andrà prima Adesso sarà il vincitore
vediamo
la melanzana No no non ci credo proprio
la melanzana hai detto Ma perché la
melanzana
forse ti piace la parmigiana di
melanzane le abbiamo anche comprato
questo giochino Guardate che bello un
sacco di palline e anche questa specie
di topino qua sopra e questo le piace un
sacco Guarda il tuo giochino preferito
Che carino ma non È carinissimo è
bellissima molto agile anche
caratterialmente rispetto a Circe lei è
molto molto dolce Circe è un po' più
selvatica e forte come gatta Invece lei
è molto dolce e
coccolosa sì e le piace un sacco dormire
ma adesso le voglio far testare Questo
gioco che è troppo divertente perché
praticamente
premiamo qua sotto
ed esce il topino lo vedete si può fare
andare piano o veloce
vediamo come reagirà questo giochino
sono troppo curioso guarda
vero amore mio ma non capisco se vuole
provare a prendere il topino oppure è un
po' confusa
come tu è carina metto l'attacco È
bellissima questa gattina
e
lo sai che potresti giocare con questo
topino non lo devi solo guardare puoi
anche giocare
piccola ecco che parte all'attacco forse
no ci ha ripensato
Non sono sicura se questo qui
ecco finalmente l'ha colpito Vediamo se
proverà a mangiarselo Ehi ma come ti
permette questo topino a giocare qua
mentre ci sono io gatto Merlino che cosa
ne pensi della nuova sorellina
ho sonno
sta prendendo sempre più confidenza col
topino magari ora lo strapperà via
è riuscita a prenderlo Sì ma cosa
succede se mettiamo il gioco che le
piace tanto qua la melanzana Ehi anche
Berlino sembra incuriosito dal topino
elettronico e Ma che è questa cosa
[Musica]
non ci credo È riuscita già a rompere il
gioco
Comunque si sta divertendo un sacco Ok
mentre la piccolina gioca noi vi diciamo
il nome adesso in realtà per Vitale è
una novità perché l'ho deciso io da sola
annunciamo adesso Allora siccome lei è
così carino Ho deciso di chiamarlo a
scorreggina Ma che stai dicendo
No non ci sono Non si può chiamare
scoreggina Sì dai lo sta bene come nome
Dai perché no è un bellissimo nome
Allora chiamiamo la Gina Solo Gina
Hahaha
No era uno scherzo speravo che ci
cascassi ma non ci sei cascato Cioè
forse ci sei cascato ma non
posto troppo al nome mi piace scoreggina
comunque la verità è che
non abbiamo ancora un nome non sappiamo
come chiamarla infatti abbiamo bisogno
del vostro aiuto
scriveteci nei commenti come potremmo
chiamarla Quindi in base a tutte le
informazioni che abbiamo che vi abbiamo
dato su di lei e cioè come è arrivata da
noi e il suo carattere
ti aspetto
è troppo carina Anche bianca e gialla
consigliateci il nome nei commenti e se
questo video raggiunge i 10.000 mi piace
faremo un altro video in cui sveleremo
il nome che abbiamo scelto Sì ma non
scorreggina però eh quindi
spolliciate Sotto questo video lasciate
un bel mi piace e consigliateci il nome
nei commenti e vi salutano i due
piccolini anche se Merlino non è più
tanto piccolino vi saluta la piccolina
che sicuramente giocherà tutto il
pomeriggio con questo gioco
prossimo video
adesso diciamo